It is time for hatred, male hatred at male
in 2020 becoming increasingly belligerent.
It's hard to believe given the last seven
years of it, but it is happening. Quick reminder.
What is hatred? Mail.
So what if the president's been accused of
sexual Harrison 15 times or that he paid hush
money to a porn star? At least he never wore
a tan suit. Hey, Trian male written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom.
Okay. And let's get in directly to this week's
hatred. Male episode.
What a loser. It is stupid. David Pakman is
total liar. Slanderer. David Pakman is the
poster boy for the leftist. Super progressive,
politically correct, sensitive snowflakes.
I doubt this scrawny loser has a single black
friend, David beta Pacman. You are so bigly
wrong. No collusion, loser, sad. You are a
bitter, uneducated, racist, selfish loser.
The black friend thing is kind of funny to
me. You would think that someone who questions
how many black friends I have would be a leftist
saying, Hey, it's important to have, you know,
a diverse group of friends or something like
that, but I think that when right wingers
ask, how many black friends do you have of
a, of a left winger? I think generally they're
making a racist point. Like you might defend
minorities on your, but you don't actually
want to be around minorities or something
like that. Any, anybody experienced this before?
I think that's the gist of right-wingers.
Asking left-wingers do you have any black
friends? I'm speculating, but maybe someone
can interpret for me. Remember that the best
way to fight the hatreds is to use the coupon
code hatred at 40 when you sign up for a membership
on my website, join pacman.com the coupon
code Patriot 40 saves you 40% Patriots.
Just start crying whenever that coupon code
is used because they know, uh, that they are
impotent in their hatred, chaotic attacks.
That coupon code of course is spelled H, a,
T, R. I. O. T, four zero.